d'un côté l'industrie agroalimentaire de
l'autre le consommateur une guerre à
finir contre le sodium qui ne date pas
d'hier en 2002 nous en parlions déjà
avec la nutritionniste
chantal blais
de 75 % la consommation la consommation
de sel dans les aliments qui sont
transformées vingt ans plus tard les
choses n'ont pas beaucoup changé près de
67 % celle que nous ingérons vient des
aliments transformés je pense qu'il faut
bouger à ce niveau là quand le groupe de
travail sur le sodium de santé canada a
déposé son rapport en 2010 l'intention
était de donner cinq ans à l'industrie
avec un objectif de réduction de 5% par
année sur cinq ans pour qu'en 2016 on
arrive à un seuil de consommation
maximum moyenne dans la population
qu'ils soient de 2300 mg à savoir
l'apport maximal tolérable en sodium
c'était seul objectif
selon le rapport déposé par santé canada
en 2017 les canadiens consomment en
moyenne 2007 160 mg de sodium par jour
bien qu'il s'agisse d'une amélioration
comparé aux 3400 mg de 2004 notre
consommation dépassent toujours
l'objectif de 2300 mg par jour pour
qu'on ait plus de difficultés à le
diminuer laissez-le plusieurs fonctions
oui une partie fonctionnelle thé mais
oui une partie aussi creux au sort de
près celle à cet effet la de plaisir en
bourse qui vient compléter par exemple
avec une notion souscrit c'est le cas
par exemple dans les céréales dans les
pins dans les produits de boulangerie
chez syntec on offre des services en
recherche et développement pour les
entreprises agroalimentaires
l'appréciation du goût salé y est mesuré
est ce que dans vos locaux de diction
les gens sont préoccupés par la teneur
en sodium des produits au point pour
ceux qui sont préoccupés par là les
ingrédients par le tableau dames en
utilisent majoritairement c'est au tour
de la teneur en sodium
je pense qu'il faut composer avantage
pour que l'esprit fasse mieux que des
effets significatifs afin certains pays
comme la finlande et la grande-bretagne
ont imposés à l'industrie de réduire
celles au canada le programme reste
volontaire
l'industrie a le droit de faire le choix
ou de ne pas faire le choix c'est
volontaire alors que si c'était quelque
chose qui était imposé je devrais me
conformer à cette réglementation le les
acteurs de l'industrie agroalimentaire
sont de fins stratèges ont dit qu entre
10 et 20% de réduction du sodium sa part
sous le radar puis les papilles
gustatives s'en rend pas trop compte
donc qu'il faut qu'on amène l'industrie
à faire des changements évidemment eux
ne veulent pas perdre d'argent donc ils
veulent vendre autant leurs produits la
plus grande platée gic les industriels
ont adopté pour viser une diminution
c'est à dire d'aller progressisme
nouvelles idées à chacune des fois de
pau choqué le consommateur mais tu es
allé progressivement puis de pau le
mentionner non plus sur l'emballage pour
procréer de deux fois aux attentes puis
après ça prend un certain temps pouvoir
j'ai dîné au bout de 10 92 30 pour ça
mon apparence et beaucoup de produits
sont ainsi reformuler au fil du temps un
exercice difficile parce que le sel
change beaucoup les propriétés des
aliments surtout leur saveur leur
texture et leur apparence le sel est
aussi nécessaire dans l'élaboration de
nombreux produits comme ceux de vous
ange riz pâtisserie et fromages il y en
a partout dans notre alimentation en
général dans ce sens dans tous les
groupes d'aliments sucrés salés peu
importe et là je parle essentiellement
des aliments transformés c'est non
seulement pas facile de s'en débarrasser
mais on pourra faire un exercice pour
voir à quel point le sodium il y en a
vraiment partout
exemple exemple journée type du déjeuner
au souper avec des aliments transformés
tout simple machine à café glacé au
déjeuner au dîner une salade de thon un
jus de légumes un petit bourg et une
galette alavoine collation de petits
bâtonnets de sésame on pourrait prendre
des crudités avec la trempette et au
souper par farcie sauce tomate salade
vinaigrette et tout ça pour un total de
mg de sodium de
3747 h puis on devrait être à 2003 ça
j'ai pas micro c gepa mille dessert
c'est ça c'est une belle démonstration
c'est juste pour montrer à quel point
avec les aliments transformés ça monte
très vite donc si on ne consomme que ça
dans une journée c'est impossible d'y
arriver
impossible aussi si vous mangez trop
souvent au resto
un seul repas au resto n'en fournit
environ
2300 mg donc c'est à 100% de votre
apport en sodium c'est certain que au
restaurant c'est très difficile de
manger moins salé même si on fait des
choix santé
le sodium est essentielle à plusieurs
fonctions vitales cependant on en
consomme souvent beaucoup plus que ce
dont le corps a besoin c'est ce qui
cause des problèmes
l'hypertension est un facteur de risque
important à gérer car on sait qu environ
1 13 % des maladies chroniques
cardiovasculaires sont attribués un
apport excessif en selle
après 20 ans de discussions sur le sujet
voici encore quelques trucs pour nous
aider à combattre le sodium pour le
stadium il y à des écarts significatifs
d'une marque à l'autre alors ça vaut la
peine plutôt que de racheter l'aliment
ou complet de jeter un oeil à ses
voisins tablettes et de voir quels
autres produits similaires nous est
proposé qui répondraient tout autant à
nos goûts et qui est moins salée sachez
que selon les experts en seulement
quelques semaines on peut aussi se
déprogrammer du goût salé
il possible pour un con ça m'en parle de
voir une évolution au niveau de sa
perception du goût salé et d'avoir une
plus grande acceptabilité aux produits
réduit en selle après quatre à six
semaines
le chiffre 2 mg de sodium soufre à lui
qu'il faut s'arrêter d'abord et avant
tout c'est le pourcentage qui est juste
à côté pourquoi le calcul est fait pour
vous si le pourcentage de l'apport
maximum par jour que vous devriez
consommer tout ce qui est accompagnement
collation quelque chose qu'on devrait
mangeant plus petites quantités faut que
ce soit en votre 15 pour ça un repos
complet c'est normal qu'ils aient plus
de sodium donc si vous avez 20 à 25 % de
l'apport maximal tolérable il n'y a pas
de panique lors du tout les gens celle
de moins en moins et probablement parce
qu'ils en sont conscients
maintenant il faut qu'on les aide aussi
avec des choix alimentaires qui sont
moins salée donc ses loques l'industrie
et la restauration sont des joueurs
importants pour
offrir des produits gras salés
[Musique]